[Musica]
sono qui per condividere con voi alcune
esperienze nell'ambito dell'energia ho
avuto la fortuna di girare giappone cina
e stati uniti america latina
occupandomi proprio di analizzare
situazioni di business nelle varie parti
del mondo per l'energia
ho maturato quindi tutta una situazione
che mondiale che mi permette di
condividere con voi alcune situazioni
non vi parlerò quindi di kilowatt ora ma
vi parlerò di come questi sistemi di
come questo modo di concepire l'energia
che sta evolvendo in questi ultimi anni
potrà determinare il nostro futuro e
vivono vi voglio guidare attorno a
questo concetto
noi finora permettetemi o la spada di
maestro yoda
abbiamo avuto una evoluzione del sistema
delle energie abbastanza lineare
attraverso varie tecnologie buone o
cattive che siano siamo arrivati a oggi
che stiamo parlando di energia
rinnovabile bene le energie rinnovabili
hanno molto di più sotto di loro hanno
delle cose che veramente ci danno da
pensare per il futuro c'è questo mondo e
questa è la figura completa di come si
sta evolvendo
questo è preso grazie al duke power che
è una delle aziende che si sta
maggiormente impegnando nel determinare
i nuovi sistemi di energia come vedete
ci sono parole importanti molto anche al
di fuori dei soliti concetti di energia
su questo entreremo nel merito il voglio
dare qualche spunto su come sono
collegati al nostro futuro
per esempio si parla molto di sistemi
solari quello che mettete sopra il tetto
bene questo è un qualcosa che veramente
abilità tanti aspetti
per esempio potrebbe fare in modo che la
nostra abitazione cda di soldi non è una
cosa brutta pensare questo o avere
questo tipo di situazione
oggi ci stanno provando concretamente
aziende importanti e start up che stanno
veramente considerando come poter fare
in modo che l'azienda che la casa
diventi un qualcosa di profitto questi
sono esempi di prodotti che sono già in
commercio
questi sono però prodotti legati a quei
prodotti che sono più tecnologici da un
punto di vista di information technology
e che portano a sviluppare tutta una
serie di sistemi e piattaforme di
altissimo valore perché permettono di
mettere insieme tante cantare cose
chiaramente avendo questo tipo di
possibilità si creano tutti questi tipi
di nuovi settori industriali e di nuove
innovazioni ma vi dirò di più con un
sistema di energie innovative si parla
di ecosistema è una parola abbastanza in
voga ultimamente specialmente nel nei
business ai sit in
però qui si parla di usare questo eco
sistema per creare dei nuovi modi nuovi
città nuovi posti dove vivere meglio e
soprattutto più al passo coi tempi
perché questo che stiamo vivendo tutti è
che c'è una corsa all'innovazione una
corsa all'introduzione di cose talmente
nuove che ci perdiamo per la strada
bene le città ci possono venire in aiuto
se sono concepite pensando da questo
punto di vista con l'energia in primo
posto città che sono organizzati una
certa maniera facilitano lo scambio di
esperienze e competenze ma anche di
valori economici ci sono già degli
esempi e sono ed è possibile visitarli
gli abbiamo in giappone toyota city
toyota non è solo una casa che produce
alto a tutto un investimento enorme
forse ancora più grande dell'auto nel
campo del riale state stanno pensando
citare hanno già realizzate già
organizzate per poter vivere una certa
maniera usando bene l'energia spendendo
poco e avendo tutti i servizi attorno a
ti danno anche il tipo di casa che vuoi
a seconda delle due modi e stili di vita
comprese chiaramente le auto elettriche
in quel caso sono le loro
chiaramente ma ci sono altre città che
stanno affrontando questo tema dal punto
di vista dell'energia e cercano di
mettere insieme il sistema energetico
con per esempio guardate la creatività
c'è tutto un fermento attorno questi
temi non possiamo pensare di avere
sistemi di energia e innovativi se non
abbiamo delle cose innovative dentro le
case attorno a noi
eccetera questo oggi è chiamato internet
of things bene internet of things se lo
se lo guardiamo dal punto di vista dei
sistemi energetici potrebbe diventare
foriero di creare una nuova silicon
valley perché apre o tutta una serie di
possibilità e di necessità di
investimenti tecnologici che possano in
qualche misura permettere di prendere
bilanciate i sistemi di energia di
essere usate le case e le energie in
maniera in maniera intelligente ma non
solo
potrebbero danno sicuramente luogo a un
sacco di informazioni devono essere
basati su intelligenza artificiale cosa
che magari pochi non conoscono possono
avere grazie a queste tecnologie che
sono da poco stanno entrando in auge
possono essere monetizzabili
non entro nei dettagli pensate a questo
se concepiamo un sistema energetico
basato sulle energie innovative e questo
con tutti questi paradigmi ci potrebbe
permettere di avere delle forme di
denaro e di pagamento
e di scambi di valore molto particolari
grazie alle tecnologie che ci sono
associate e chiaramente l'abbondanza di
informazioni che questi sistemi tre anni
e l'abbondanza di capacità di calcolo
che in questi ultimi anni è disponibile
ci permetterebbe di creare chiaramente
nuovi business e inventare nuovi servizi
la parola chiave per gli addetti ai
lavori in questi anni sono le digital
platform al piattaforme digitali
queste sono ben note in certi ambienti
come apple google amazon nel campo
dell'energia le piattaforme digitali non
ci sono quelle che ci sono sono sono
poche ma sono in embrione quindi siamo
al punto di partenza di queste cose
quindi potremmo pensare che se ci
lavoriamo bene su questo fronte
potremmo creare la google dell'energia e
anche questa non è una cosa da poco
perché voi sapete che oggi il mondo
questi signori qua che rappresentano le
piattaforme oggi disponibili sui vari i
vari continenti fatturano o meglio hanno
un pil proporzionale a tanti paesi che
noi vicini a noi e quindi quello che
voglio dirvi in conclusione ma se noi ci
guardiamo attorno e guardiamo i nostri
vicini e ci guardiamo e guardiamo anche
come competere con altri paesi accetta
nella domanda che ci possiamo porre che
energia ai l'energia innovativa se ce
l'hai vuol dire che hai sviluppato tutte
queste cose
quindi ci siamo creati un futuro da
questo punto di vista non hai le energie
innovative
allora resti indietro
questo è la morale in altri termini le
energie innovative quelle giuste
mettiamole tra virgolette sono dei
catalizzatori di un sacco di
investimenti e di grandi evoluzioni
future di grandi sviluppi
e quindi in conclusione qualenergia
vogliamo avere io dopo questa sintesi è
questo lavorare in giro per il mondo ho
le idee chiare spero di avervi dato
anche a voi qualche spunto positivo su
questo grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]